but first of all Peter brand hello thank
you for waiting patiently while I call
that house keeping and spoiling the new
video game and it away it's wonderful
great to have you here this is a tech
time as ever I saw over the weekend we
put on a Heuer was a dismissive bad as
ever guess it's time to look at some
back in technology at you have been
playing the Retron 5 for the past couple
of weeks I know I've been working with
those guys because it's the hardware
isn't out there yes and your review went
up over the weekends sort of breaking
down the pros and cons but at the moment
and you're gonna show us it now can you
give us a skivvy I'm what exact how what
is this machine first of all and is it
fitted for the purpose intended right
now yes okay okay so basically what this
is is a a new system that plays a lot of
old games you have Nintendo's Super
Nintendo Genesis but also the Japanese
variants you got Famicom Super Famicom
and then gameboy game boy color and Game
Boy Advance games as well now you need
to have the original cartridges for this
and a high / Kens released a few
products licet like this in the past is
their latest one it uses an embedded
android operating system okay which
means that is basically it's using
emulation right it's not a one-to-one
system but the cool thing about that is
you've hdmi out you can do things like
but graphical filters on you can use
save states if you're really bad at old
games like me hmm even though games are
hard yeah and I'm really bad at that so
so save states kind of give me an upper
hand uh but yeah I mean this thing is
it's not quite perfect it's not quite
there yet it's coming out june sixth
after like 10 months of being delayed
yeah but for the most part it's pretty
great in terms of the imperfections are
we talking software stuff that they can
like push new firmware to it or yeah so
this is a great thing it's got android
so they can update it right now there's
some incompatibility with a few games
that use special chips but it's it's not
that that many games that don't really
work oddly you can't have more than one
cartridge in the system at a time right
but okay four slots for cartridges I
know you can't stack them up now you
can't but that's it that should change
hopefully can we love it look at the
controller as well because obviously
this is this is this the only one you
can use no you can use the original
controller Super Nintendo Genesis or
Nintendo okay and those can all be
reprogrammed for any of the systems you
want and if you have four controllers
for any system you can plug those in and
pretend Lee give a multi-tap and play
four player games slough
one thing you can t say we can even play
like Genesis games with a Super NES
controller you got it wow that's weird
or with a Nintendo controller if you're
weird like at nes one but what you
cannot do is multiplayer game boy games
because that requires a link cable right
it's not really a thing with this okay
but it seems to take a lot of boxes it
takes a lot of bucks how is this guy cuz
it's got an analog stick on an odd d-pad
right well so what it has is a it's a
pad with micro switches underneath okay
um which is good for things like
fighting games show it again well dr.
Mike and move it around a little bit
yeah it's right here no no like actually
the thumbstick because it makes makes
clicky noises it's like an eight-way it
like clicks at the stations right up
down left right yells its kind of
obnoxious and she's feeling to be honest
with you but it works and uh yeah well
here we going to play some sonic 3 why
don't we do that yeah let's hop straight
in so this is a game that an old
cartridge that you had I know people
going to ask so i'll just ask get it
away do this thing does not take roms or
anything of that nature no but you know
it's running android and if the you know
nerd community is taught me anything
said they will hack anything that they
can write and that will probably include
this over time but for the moment yeah
it's totally locked down to legit
cartridges and you know i call it games
anyway like I i use emulation when I
have to but for the most part I really
appreciate having the real thing so for
me this is wonderful because I actually
get to play the games on modern TVs
without they like delay present with
upscaling from old systems and nothing a
problem in terms of like hdmi with hdcp
or with with nah i think of that nature
no telling us up know if you have any
questions for Peter same as ever put
them in the chopped put them in the
comments and i'll send them a question
let's do it what so this is the Retron 5
yep you're probably wondering what
happened to the Retron for so there have
been retron before this and we've you
know we've had them in the office when
we played around with them is there a
story about the restaurant for you want
to tell or can we just want I was
curious about like the iteration like
where it would yeah what has been added
in here what makes this like the the
I mean has it been vastly improved over
what you can get maybe an older sister I
mean yeah basically so the restaurant
for was announced about a year and a
half ago and that was what the Retron 5
is now but then they added support for
gameboy games so that kind of changed up
the whole number scheme and well just
they're not gonna come out of the Retron
for I don't think was there three once
you get that are free and the numbers it
your feel free to skip any number you
want that's the one Entertainment has
set that precedent so was there a
situation in which like you should wait
until the Retron 6 comes out like how
they're also nintendo 64 is the one
cartridge system that a lot of people
are asking for right the only reason
that's not in here is because the
patents on the hardware is still valid
okay so I once that runs out i believe
in 2016 Wow quote me on that they should
have something you know that will play
to 10 of 64 games the guys have already
said that hyper can the company that
makes this that they they have that
working in-house it's not a product that
they can put on the market so help our
way from me from out yeah yeah it's work
I have no way of emerald for years like
though I have far away from having like
PlayStation 1 versions of this are we
well I mean I think that's going to come
down to what they want to do as a
company right because these you don't
have moving parts in these right it's
just a cartridge slot and like an
embedded Android computer PlayStation
stuff you're going to have you know
discs to contend with moving parts and
lenses and it's a lot more you know
places for things to go wrong and hyper
cane is facing a bout of consumer lash
back because has been delayed so long
and the prices raised even forty percent
oh well how much is it one hundred forty
dollars ok so what it was 100 bucks
before it was a hundred dollars they
their initial manufacturing process led
to some errors and they actually
redesigned the chassis to support Sega
Master System games and to fix the
errors that they were experiencing I
don't really know what those were but
you know overall I like this thing I
this is one that they sent us for review
i'm probably going to buy one of my own
for home because like i said playing
game damn it talking about you do it oh
don't crevel right now talking so at any
time if you see megabit you knew it
basically you know when you try to use
old systems which i actually prefer to
do it it's better on a CRT TV because
the timing is right the games look the
way they should
on a LCD there they're totally stretched
you press a a few milliseconds or frames
later that's when it actually takes and
that's not really good for when games
are so difficult yeah I've got a couple
of questions here gonna get you quick
auntie V aunty aunty van T is asked that
doesn't have any CRT emulation filters
yes it does have a scan line filter you
can throw on top and it has the similar
filters you would find in emulators such
as like super eagle and all those great
naming things they smooth out the pixels
yeah you actually want to poke around in
the menu of this at all oh yeah yeah let
me do uh I'll show you guys what we got
but Papa turn on there's that save space
stuff you got you can pop these filters
on just right from the in-game menu yeah
they're the scan lines which take away
some of this meeting but you can you can
tell you without you know the scanlines
present that is a little bit nicer at
noodle legs asked have you ever noticed
any lag when any of the emulations while
running on HD no because this outputs
native resolution your TV so there is no
processing of the video at least in
terms of the TV which before was the
correlation or where'd like ovens oh
cool so yeah it's pretty great sweet ah
thanks very much Peter for coming online
showing off the Retron 5 going anywhere
I'm gonna keep you notice i'll keep
playing all real